how many people have filed for Bitcoin
ETF there's one Bitcoin there's eight
guys trying to do the Bitcoin ETF
there's one Bitcoin so they're all the
same so once all these Traders adopt a
structure to trade Bitcoin and have
custodial abilities which isn't that
hard and they're doing this right now
and Fidelity is the leader it's gonna
happen and it's gonna happen next year
traditional institutions will take it
over they'll start doing ETFs and
Bitcoin will rise again and everybody
will get excited again but to try to
argue that we don't need a digital
currency that's Global that isn't
controlled by a government it's like
it's more necessary than ever
how are you well you know I'm I'm in a
really bad mood about Elon right now
why what's he doing
well he's attacking the Jews
and you know he's accusing the
Anti-Defamation League of defamation
think about that for just a couple
seconds like logically
you know I'm supposed to be one of the
smartest men on Earth and here's an
organization that spends their entire
life like fighting racism
forever nobody's perfect but you know
they try really hard I support them for
a long time
and the bottom line is there's lots of
hate speech on Twitter you know like I'm
sorry Free Speech if you're just not
going to moderate speech you're going to
get a lot of hateful people on your
platform that's just the way it is
imagine the video game platforms if they
didn't moderate speech right and um
and so then adl's like well we can't
recommend this as a platform for
advertisers so Elon goes after them you
know and then he's like well I'm not
anti-semitic I just support the people
who are okay you know and I'm just like
do you think do you think that
he is anti-Semitic or do you think that
he okay so here's the part that is
always interesting to me in these
situations is
whoever the CEO of Twitter is or whoever
owns Twitter what do you think is like
the right move does he like play nice
with the ADL and like bring the hammer
down on the platform but you're trying
to do free speech like like if you were
them what would you do like how do you
kind of handle you know a very complex
situation when when I'm an investor in X
and when they called me and said you
know because I said I'm interested and
they called me back and they said you
know
and I said who's going to be CEO and
they're like Elon and I go that's a
horrible idea you know you don't want to
be the person moderating speech and they
said well he probably won't be for long
but whatever and I go but but don't you
understand you don't want to be the
person moderating speech in America or
the world it is a horrible job to have
you cannot win with this job right so
the way you do it is you put together
like a group of people that are
transparent that create moderate rules
okay so it's not a hundred percent free
speech it's just not it's a private
platform and you sell advertising so my
my thing is if you want to do what he's
doing you can't be pissed at the ADL and
you can't be pissed at all the the
organizations that say this isn't really
a great place to advertise you just
can't be pissed so I'm saying fine do
what you're doing but don't attack all
the people who don't want to be a part
of your platform
or you create a platform that's good for
advertisers and users and advertisers
will flock to it so you know you can't
have it both ways that's what I would
say so in my mind
moderation is an extremely difficult
thing and so you take the two ends of
the extreme and you put a panel together
of the two ends of the extreme you know
moderators and then you look at content
you take it out and you're going to take
down extreme left-wing stuff you're
going to take down extreme right-wing
stuff and people are going to complain
about it but what happens is the 95
percent of users in the in the middle
have a better experience and so
so it's kind of like running uh you know
like an event you have an event and
people get too drunk you know it's like
well it was a drinking event well do you
want the drunk guy hitting on all the
girls and getting in a fight or do you
kick them out of the bar and you're like
this is a bar I came here to drink now
I'm drunk and you're saying you don't
like it
you see what I'm saying but they kick
you out because the other 95 percent of
people don't want this drunk idiot
puking on everybody and hitting hitting
people you know what I mean
so it's your bar
so what's interesting about this is the
other platforms do take down the content
and obviously they have the advertisers
but people are pissed people being the
users are pissed about censorship and
the lack of free speech and all of that
and so do you think that it's the loud
minority of people on the Free Speech
issue and like most people actually
don't care or don't pay attention on the
other platforms like how do you then
approach the people I don't think people
care that much I I I would disagree with
that statement I think most people
prefer to have an environment that's
safe for their children to to not be
bullied you know
I don't know what your childhood was
like but I wasn't bullied most of my
childhood but there was a period of time
I think I was in like fifth or sixth
grade that I there's a group of kids I
didn't like and and they were the
majority and I started getting bullied
because of it and it sucked and back
then teachers didn't help you there was
no you know like you just got your butt
kicked you know and I got my butt kicked
once and I was like
you know and I'll never forget it and I
decided I would really fight back next
time you know what I mean and when
you're on the other side of bullying it
sucks and so when you have a platform
for adults do you want it to be a free
sharing of ideas that's the goal isn't
it supposed to be the Town Square a free
sharing idea but you got a bunch of
Nazis in the corner that will bully and
attack you if you share your ideas which
is what happens to me now you know being
an independent middle person if I share
any idea that's at all liberal like you
just get bullied out of the park so it's
like you know I'm kind of like whatever
is that what's best so I think a lot of
people don't care they want to just use
Facebook and look at pictures of their
friends and they don't want extremists
thing they don't care about politics a
hundred percent of people I talk to
today don't want to be involved with
politics or the news they just don't I I
like I literally talk to people and
they're like I didn't read that I don't
want to read that I don't read the
papers anymore I don't follow social
media anymore like people just checked
out from it because it's so you know
hostile you know what are they doing
with their time I thought everyone just
spent a doom scrolling on the internet
they're on Netflix right you know
Netflix has got like 10 billion hours of
viewing every day you know it's like
it's crazy they're on YouTube uh they're
on Roblox they're on Call of Duty you
know like I play video games and we got
a huge community of friends my age on
Call of Duty like my whole team is
people over 50 you know it's kind of
funny and uh so it's kind of a joke
because we like kill children every day
you know it's like kind of funny now
they moderate speech on the platform
because you can talk to the other
players in game like when you get close
to them it's called proximity chat and
if they didn't moderate it you get a
bunch of racist stuff because that's
just what happens but because they
moderate it it's like the funnest thing
ever you know it's like you're taking
out kids and you hear them crying and
complaining you know and we're laughing
at them and you know it's just it's a
great platform Call of Duty is a great
platform so we all go there and try to
kill and you know blow each other up and
and because there's moderation it's a
lot of fun and and people you know enjoy
playing the game
what do you think of elon's job so far
with Twitter or ax do you think it's
going well it's not going well you're an
investor so like would you knowing
everything you know now would you have
invested again
um no I wouldn't have I wouldn't have
invested again but it has nothing to do
with the investment uh uh possibility or
thesis it would has more to do with what
x has become I I don't agree with it
personally I don't need to make money
you know see I'm one of those people who
has enough money I don't spend so much
money that I have to keep working or
this or that so I'm one of those people
that chooses the way I want to live and
what I believe in I don't need to invest
in stuff to make money if I don't
believe in it and I originally believed
in the vision of it and now it feels
like it's gone off the rails and I don't
I just don't need to make money from it
so I would personally not necessarily
want to be involved now I hope it writes
the ship you know I hope
I don't think Elon is like ignorant I I
just think
his skill set isn't really these things
and so
he's just constantly like making errors
you know
so I think that's a bigger issue with
Linda in charge you know that was a big
plus you know in the right direction I
think but I still think as a economic
vehicle Twitter will struggle mightily
without advertisers and why would
anybody advertise on the platform they
have made no argument of the value
proposition of that advertising on
Twitter versus spending my ad dollars on
ad supported Netflix which I know people
are watching Outer Banks right now and I
put an ad on Outer Banks I got all this
young demo watching it you know so
advertisers are dumb they need to
maximize their ad dollars so as an
investor I think he's making mistakes
and as a person I think he's making
mistakes I think he's heard his brand so
you can say oh his Brand's you know
grown among a group of people that don't
buy Teslas and it's gotten destroyed
among people who are his best customers
you know people have uh bumper stickers
in California that says love the company
not the man and they put it on their
Teslas you know and I saw that the other
day like geez that's a statement you
know it's like people want to drive
Teslas and they literally feel bad
buying them because they because the
Elon you know and it just doesn't make
sense the whole thing doesn't make sense
to me so you think that do you think
that there's a lot of people with those
bumper stickers or it was like a one-off
no I don't think there's a lot of people
but but I think that
um I don't talk to anybody in California
now that doesn't hate Elon like it's
it's almost like I was at a party the
other day and they were asking me what I
do and whatever and I was like and the
guy was in the investment business
section I was like you don't watch CNBC
you don't follow Tesla you don't follow
Nvidia you don't watch the pond podcast
you don't watch me Kevin you don't read
The Wall Street Journal you know you
know like I'm literally
he's like no I don't
know what's this it's like yeah I do
corporate financing you know or whatever
but you know then you bring up Elon and
it's um it's like everybody's like f him
you know and I was like and they're like
you know him and I was like not really
you know it's like I I was a Tesla
investor I am a Tesla investor and it
used to be like I'd go to a party and
everybody would be like wow this is so
great oh elon's great you know
not anymore do you think he cares
no
I don't think he cares I I think if you
surround yourself with people who love
you and you pay them a lot of money like
they love you now I've managed to not be
successful with that I surround myself a
lot of people I pay a lot of money or
make a lot of money who don't
necessarily love me all the time and I
think that's a huge benefit to my
company
when we look at Tesla what do you take
with the price Cuts some people think
that it's a huge advantage and they're
cutting prices while giving more value
to customers when you look at other
people they're like they can't move cars
and so the best way to drum up demand is
to cut prices which one do you think it
is it's number two
it's number two hundred percent okay now
I just drove to work and
um I saw a Mercedes eqs the new Mercedes
eqs and it's sweet I'm sorry it's a nice
car
you got to compete with it yeah okay my
business partner just bought the BMW i7
electric it's a beautiful car massive
just but the inside is great my business
partner my other one just drove in with
his new rivian RTS beautiful SUV
wonderful car okay people driving they
what is the uh the ionic or something
five the Hyundai I see the id4s I see uh
pole Stars I see
um trucks the rivian trucks the Ford
maches this was not the case two years
ago you know like when Tesla was at a
high two years ago 400 bucks trading 100
times earnings okay there was nobody
like this and remember Tesla could only
make a million cars a year now they
rapidly increase production now they're
two million cars a year but same with
everybody else
so the CEO of the company figures how
what's the best way to sell cars piss
off all my customers okay like just piss
them off now one great way to do it is
have them buy a car let's say last year
for 75 000 that they can now buy today
for forty five thousand dollars okay
what what do you think the customer says
when that happens
they're like super pissed so you have
like two years the majority of Tesla
buyers have gotten screwed essentially
where they paid a certain amount for a
car not knowing that it would they would
rapidly decrease the prices within a
year okay
and it's like a free fall in prices you
know like the I have a model X plaid
that I bought for like I don't know 135
uh two years ago and today I can sell
for 82 000 but a year and a half ago I
could have made them money on my car
Teslas were growing in value because the
supply and demand were opposite it was
like huge amount of demand not enough
supply of cars so how do you increase
demand when you have an increasing
Supply you have increasing competition
right so the first thing you do is you
advertise this is what I've been saying
for now seven months now Tesla's idea of
advertising is they have upgraded the
referral program they've done all kinds
of cool ways in the past you know I just
saw them have a booth at the Malibu
chili cook-off and it's out in the
corner and I got a booth and two guys
standing there I go that's not
advertising so football season starts
next weekend this weekend okay how
excited are you pump because I'm excited
okay I think every man in America almost
looks forward to this weekend right like
I'm in MGM stock I couldn't be happier
Sports books are open Vegas is going to
be back the stadiums will be filled with
fans like where's Tesla advertising so
all you have to do is ask somebody who
doesn't own a Tesla what they know about
electric vehicles and you'll quickly
learn they know nothing
they don't know any of the advantages
like it costs six times less to operate
the vehicle than a gas car just
just that alone okay most people have no
idea most people think that oh it's a
real big pain to charge okay it's not
you know it takes 10 minutes now you
know 15 minutes to charge in a
supercharger it used to take 30 or 40
minutes not at all people don't know so
here they could be taking football ads
it would cost them 20 million 25 million
that's a drop in the bucket for Tesla
doing 100 billion in Revenue right and
educate the public with just a bunch of
NBA and Super Bowl ads where they've got
all these great creators make all these
great videos that get everybody pumped
and if they ran these ads I think people
would go nuts like it would be wow you
mean I could buy a model y for 45k and
get a bunch of tax credits to get this
thing down to thirty thousand dollars
people don't know I can sell Teslas all
day long okay all day long
but they don't do this they don't do
this
at one point I saw you talking about uh
potentially joining the board of
directors of Tesla is that the big thing
that you would be focused on is the
marketing are there other things that
you think are important for the business
well back then I was trying to force the
board well it turned out I was right the
board was all paid hundreds of millions
of dollars by Elon not to say anything
which now in a lawsuit they have lost
and the board of directors of Tesla will
be returning
730 million dollars in compensation to
shareholders that they were
um paid which I guess you could say not
illegally but uh not correctly and
they're returning money I mean like it's
a crazy amount of money for five or six
people to have to return 700 million
right
explain this a little bit more because I
don't think most people understand this
is happening so what happened and then
what are they having to do so what
happened was last year when Tesla when
Elon decided by Twitter Tesla's board
did not protect Tesla shareholders at
all the stock fell 60 to 70 it was very
detrimental to many people it was very
costly to people like me as well
um you know I was probably down you know
50 60 million on the position not as
profits that we lost but like still it's
like what are you doing and then Elon
was selling stock in the open market
throughout the year and often at
inopportune times so you had this 20 or
30 billion dollars of stock sales on top
of you know he's buying another company
and the board did really nothing to
protect Tesla shareholders during this
period of time so I finally got pissed
when the stock hit 100 and this guy from
Singapore calls me uh kogan Leo and he's
one of the biggest individual
shareholders in Tesla and he's like Elon
this is not good somebody needs to reign
in this guy I love him but you know it's
like he's killing us you know and and I
said well maybe I'll run for the board
but you have to support me because I
can't win anything without some real
votes and he's like 100 so I had a good
chunk of stuff stock that was going to
vote for me and then it turned out that
most of the institutional shareholders
are very unhappy with the board as well
and and it turned out I probably could
have won so that's that's when I got
scared you know because at first I was
just an activist and then I really
realized I had a tremendous amount of
support
um but then when I looked into it I was
like dude this is like diving into World
War One you know and part of it was the
fact that the board was each paid 200
million each by Elon and I had never
seen that in a board in my life and I
didn't know that until I started looking
into this and then I was like how the
hell is Robin delham worth 300 million
dollars or something when she worked at
telestra in Australia like there's no
way and then I looked it was all options
from Tesla and I go how is this possible
board members make like 400k a year you
know like at most companies and that's
like reasonable that's more than
reasonable you know for a couple
meetings a year and whatever
so how do you get from 400k a year to
like 200 million right you know
so I knew something was off and how much
of that was options that were given at a
really low price the stock price
explodes and that accounts for a huge
part of it versus they're literally
getting you know 200 million dollars at
a high stock price and it's almost like
I'm issuing this person 200 million
dollars right it's a combination about
so he didn't issue people 200 million
but many of them had only been on the
board for two or three years so it was
like they were kind of given this gift
so they got a huge amount of stock
options that was way more like a board
member should not get a million dollars
in stock droppings or five million
dollars in shop stock options it's just
it's like absurd you know and and
clearly shareholders weren't really
privy to this and and so there was a
lawsuit and the lawsuit was just settled
by the board of directors of Tesla for
730 million and basically each
individual board member has to give back
like 200 million it's crazy okay I've
never seen this in my life and I go no
and and so when I started pushing for
things like advertising transparency
succession planning you know some sort
of like normalcy at a you know 700
billion dollar company
um you know the Tesla started adjusting
to those things so when I talked to
Tesla they were like we want to do all
these things but it's Elon you know and
I was like so they're basically like
yeah go ahead Ross you can go try to
convince him because well all looked and
fired you know so if you go to Elon and
you say this is a good idea he'll fire
you so nobody's gonna go do that at
Tesla so they're like all for it so
after much negotiation they ended up
doing investor day which I flew out for
and they and they did all this like song
and dance here all the executives and
then they fire Zach who they present as
the you know the next guy you know so
Elon gets her gets Linda yaccarino and
comes back to Tesla and the guy they
anoint is the number two of Tesla Zach
they a fire or whatever happens to them
right and I'm not that's just like
what's next dude you know the whole
purpose of secession plan was to build
Drew and Zach and all these other
leaders Tom Shu and the minute he gets
back he fires the best guy
and they can say oh he didn't fire him
it's like well why would he quit you
know
how long had he been there
13 years he was like the guy you know
this guy maybe you think maybe he was
just tired he just wanted to retire he's
30 years old
30. you tires he started working at 17.
no he started like out of college
somebody's 35. I mean look he's a kid
he's a kid bomb are you tired
how old are you I'm 52 I'm not tired you
give me 500 million I'll get up early
you know what I mean
he doesn't even have a family to spend
time with you know but one little loan
fact was he is gay and so you know
there's all kinds of things that go on
that we don't see but he lost the key
guy I don't care what you want to say
you can spin it you can say this or that
he lost a key guy
who's really good really good you know I
I'm I'm like I'm sure he's going to show
up at Google or some somewhere pretty
soon but but nevertheless I
I feel like the board
evens to this day you know pretty much
lets Elon do what he's going to do and
and that's that look at the SpaceX
article today SpaceX gave Elon a billion
dollars to tide him over during the the
Twitter nightmare
you know so he could sell more Tesla
stock and then pay back SpaceX that's
basically what happened
so he didn't even have enough cash to
buy Twitter so when when the deal
actually went through he's like
borrowing money and all this kind of
stuff so it's front page to Wall Street
Journal today he's like just using
SpaceX as his piggy bank basically now
I'm going
this is like a massive 150 billion
dollar space company and the CEO can
just borrow a billion bucks for the
month so he can do something else
it's only only a Tesla or SpaceX or
whatever so
so in SpaceX case it's a private company
so they can do what they want but in
Tesla's cup it's a public company and
you can't do these things and that's why
there's so many lawsuits and SEC
investigations and nonsense that goes on
around Tesla Tesla has the glass house
investigation The Glass House what's
going on with that that's a nonsense
nonsense I mean first of all elon's
crazy so he might do stuff that but he
doesn't care about himself at all like
like he's the most
non-self-wealth interested
person and who's wealthy that I know
like I hang out with some of these
billionaire people and you go over to
their like mini hotels because they're
not houses anymore you're you're if you
have a big house you're not that wealthy
anymore you have to have a mini Hotel
okay so that's what they do here in
California is the billionaires build
these mini hotels that they live in it's
like going to the Four Seasons okay so
like you show up at their house and
they've got like the staff and the whole
bit and they take your car and then they
offer you hors d'oeuvres and it is the
Four Seasons That's how these people
live Elon sleeps on a couch like at the
factory you sleeping he got in trouble
at Twitter because he put a bunch of
beds upstairs in the offices and it's
like we're all sleep here you know and
like he's legendary for this he has like
massive back problems because he doesn't
sleep on a regular bed half the time
like
he's perfectly happy sleeping in a car
kind of guy so the idea that he's
somehow absconding with like resources
of Tesla to build some glass house you
know
SEC is getting a little bit desperate in
their investigations that's what I think
but
one thing I'm sure of is that he is 100
focused on his goals whether it be Mars
or Tesla or neurolink or AI now
and like personal wealth stuff is not
him you know if he was used to have
houses and stuff but he sold them all
you know
if Elon started another company tomorrow
and he called you up and he said hey I
want you to invest would you do it
probably yeah
all right what would cause you to sell
what would cause you to sell the Tesla
position
well right now
you know I'm a long-term investor so
my firm and my basic wealth belief
system is you own these great companies
that produce tons of cash and take care
of their shareholders and you just hold
those forever you know
um it was funny because Jimmy Buffett
just died and I was a huge fan I had met
him once got to spend the day with him
and it was just a super amazing day and
he owned Berkshire Hathaway because he
knew Warren Buffett and that was like
the only stock he owned and and he just
owned it for like 25 or 30 years and I
was like yeah it's got the highest
returns of any investor right you know
he's got Berkshire Hathaway for 30 years
you know you can't do wrong with that
right and did you ever hear have you
ever heard the story of the first time
they ever talked I I have heard that
story it was like coincidental wasn't it
or something like that
so the part that I heard is they get on
the phone and Buffett's like hello and
Jimmy Buffett says cousin Warren right
and right and more Warren realizes
what's going on so he goes cousin Jimmy
and supposedly for the rest of their
lives Warren Buffett and Jimmy Buffett
called each other cousins because they
shared the last name yeah I think that's
true and and that was in the paper today
yeah
um you know
I think Jimmy Buffett was one of the
greater business people I have ever met
and I was so lucky because I got to have
lunch with him and you know whenever I
get these like it's pretty rare where I
get these opportunities to be around
these people I don't like I ask
questions you know what I mean I'm like
I've been I'm with a legend I'm not
gonna sit here and just like blow smoke
you know back and forth up you know what
oh you're great you're great I'm like
let's talk business like how have you
done this like how do you manage this
like what do you own you know and he
starts telling me about all his projects
and and one of the things about Jimmy
Buffett that really caught me like right
off the bat
for Successful People number one was he
loved business like he was like a
Relentless marketer you know like
he wrote a couple great songs you know
that but they're like three chord songs
and he turned these songs into a brand
and he turned this brand into like
multiple verticals that ultimately I
think he was worth hundreds of millions
of dollars from hotels and retirement
communities to to live shows and bars
and restaurants and you know I mean this
guy is just like went and went and went
in 100 Direction so number one he he
just like loved business and he and he
loved doing business with people he
liked he didn't he was not
solely focused on profit he wanted he
very much believed in his vision and
wanted to work with people who were
great like that he liked you know so
there was like he didn't have a lot of
conflict because of that you know going
into business with the wrong people and
he would partner with really good people
but he had just a Relentless energy and
a tremendous love of life like I've
never like for me that's the tough thing
is to balance between like having fun
and work you know it's so easy to like
do too much of one or the other
and Buffett was like great at that you
know like he was known to be super fun
and he was super fun but he also was
like a relentlessly hard worker a
perfectionist and his people were super
loyal to him he took care of his people
you know any any and we walked through a
couple things and I was like man this
guy
is a legend and I hope somebody writes a
business book on Jimmy Buffett
what do you think was his greatest like
Insight was it building the brand was it
expanding outside of just the music what
would you say you know after analyzing
after talking to him was the Insight
that he had that other people could
Implement and potentially recreate some
of the success people okay every
business is about people okay whether
you're podcasting or whether you're
selling crypto or or Investments like me
or you're in the entertainment business
or you're selling a social media
whatever you do it's about the people
and this is kind of how we started this
podcast the the goal is to make the
world happier
okay look at it this way the purpose of
life is to bring goodness and happiness
to the world and then we are God it's
pretty quick okay we have this little
moment you know and he very much
believed that his brand brought a little
bit of happiness and goodness to people
in the world and that was what
Margaritaville was it was an escape it
was like wherever you were if there was
a Margaritaville you could go in there
and get this little you know Southern
Florida Vibe and and have the margarita
and put Finn you know and like and
people love that they just loved it
because it was a little bit of happiness
that he was spread and I try to do the
same thing I I say this my firm all the
time this should be the happiest place
on Earth you know we help people plan
their Futures like this is not a bad job
we like help people plan their Futures
we want people to have a like a better
life like it's fun enjoy what you do but
if this job is about buying and selling
Tesla stock and trying to make money all
day like a hedge fund it's a lot less
fun a lot less fun because then it's
just about money and results and it's
not whether that person you know who got
married and wanted to buy a house you
actually help them do that you know like
that's a lot of fun because then they
get the house and they're like super
happy and so I think most businesses and
what Jimmy Buffett did so well was
really focus that every business that he
was in had to have this really positive
vibe it was like positivity and it drew
people into his brand and his and people
loved his brand because it gave them a
little bit of happiness and I think
that's something everybody can learn
talk about the ETF you guys have uh GK
and it seems like you guys have done
decently well markets up to start the
year you guys have done yeah
about what the uh the Market's done what
is going well there what's not going
well there and uh when you look at that
ETF structure are you still excited
about you know investing out of the ETF
structure versus other types of fund
structures
yeah you know
so ETFs
for us is a little bit different than
let's say like a ETF company like my
friend you know Gary has or or the
roundhill guys I know and or the global
ex guys we know where you know when
you're building an ETF company
it's really a difficult thing actually
and not necessarily what I want to be
doing but when you run a financial
services firm with 2.5 billion dollars
in assets and you start thinking about
like how do we scale you know so we got
to a point now where we got 45 employees
you know 12 000 clients we got
hundreds of millions a year coming in
you know a certain amount going out but
our net new flows are hundreds of
millions a year you know
um and so it goes into like how do we
manage money in scale so we use index
funds and ETFs as part of our investment
strategy mostly because they're low-cost
strategies that work our basic
philosophy is index plus Alpha so so we
very much believe the S P 500 is a great
place to invest and investors can do
great just doing that and so we'll layer
the portfolio with either one ETF or a
group of ETFs that sort of look at the
overall market now we don't invest in
oil and we don't invest in like chemical
companies and railroads you know so we
kind of try to strip out I don't like
the you know things we don't believe in
and we invest more in like like climate
and Technology you know and consumers so
our three main themes are climate
technology and consumer and so the ETF
was built to be the alpha portion of the
portfolio so it's about 35 stocks right
now and the idea with it was that there
are these advantages that ETFs have
which basically all there's no capital
gains tax you know and so for an
investor like me when we bought Tesla
and we put I know I don't know six
million seven million Tesla and we made
you know 100 times our money but we had
sold some along the way so we made a
couple hundred million and we ended up
paying tens of millions in taxes for
clients tens of tens of millions of
taxes and I was like how could we do
this in a way that next time we have a
big kill you know it's not like we lose
30 percent of it you know and then Noah
from advisor shares cosmith says well
there's this thing called ETFs where
Vanguard lobbied for a tax exemption
basically that says you can trade like a
1031 transfer out of one stock into a
bunch of other stocks and not have to
pay capital gain stocks I said well
that's that's amazing you know now I
just have to find the next Tesla so so
the ETF was a way for us to now build
portfolios use our investment strategy
manage more money in scale and because
we manage lots of small clients we can't
buy and sell 30 stocks in a small
account we can just drop the ETF in and
then when it goes up
we're not going to be producing capital
gains out of this thing so it's almost
like ideal right for a growth investment
so I was like active ETFs are a great
idea it's just a great idea and the
government looked at the tax break just
recently in the last thing and it they
just move on because it's Vanguard and
BlackRock and State Street and who knows
how much they pay right so most people
don't realize that you can invest in my
ETF I traded every week and there's no
taxes no capital gains tax now we do
earn income because we have dividends
and dividend stocks in there so
um unfortunately it's always at the top
of the market when everybody has these
great ideas
let's start an ETF at the top of the
market
and I knew it was it was just like you
know but then if you would have told me
the fed and the war and that Elon was
going to go berserk and stock was going
to go down 75 it was a brutal year in
22. it was just a brutal year for for us
you know in my traditional accounts were
balanced so we lost half as much money
that we did in the ETF in 2022 because
we're balanced you know but in the ETF
you're only seeing that strip of alpha
of stocks that we manage so this year
started and we were well ahead of the s
p for most of the year until the
correction
um in in August
um and now we've kind of pulled back and
in line with it
um but we're heavily concentrated so you
see lots of volatility in our portfolio
relative to our overall portfolios for
clients
um so I'm pretty happy with it because
you know this year has been much better
um you know a lot of the things I invest
in have had some struggles recently like
cannabis and now we're seeing some
progress in cannabis but that was you
know sort of painful in 22 uh gaming
video gaming
um crypto you know crypto was was
brutalized in 22 but I have every still
belief in these themes you know and
we're out of a lot of themes right now
but we have every intention to get back
in they're cheap you know like a lot of
these teams are cheap and and so you
know we're just having to deal with this
sort of post-pandemic
world where Arc has dealt with it a lot
worse than we have so originally we're
like hopefully we'll beat Arc we're
doing twice as well as art since we
started so so you know that that makes
me happy you know
um we could have done better
in some ways but it's always easy to do
that in hindsight you know what what is
the difference in the investment process
let's say for private clients with a
portfolio that's kind of shielded from
public scrutiny versus through the ETF
I'm assuming a huge piece of this is
also like you hear noise right whether
it's on Twitter or the mainstream media
is people can see what you're buying
they can see what you're selling God
forbid you buy something and it goes
down or you sell something and then it
goes back up right that there's always
that kind of armchair quarterback do you
guys have a different investment process
or a kind of system in place for the
public uh ETF versus maybe things that
you do in the private Market because of
that no and I own a ton of the ETFs like
so the idea is like I put I I don't know
I got a half a million in the ETF
personally and then our firm has money
in the ETF because we don't want
conflicts of interest and so it's like
you know like I think it's a great
vehicle you know and and I've been
buying my ETF you know dollar cost
averaging so I'm up on it and you know
it's like it's great because we own
Nvidia and I got 800 000 in gains on
Nvidia in the ETF that you know people
aren't going to have to pay taxes on
it's it's a wonderful thing we've also
harvested all the losses from you know
22 so like let's say they're six or
seven million dollars of losses that we
harvested so if you buy my ETF today
you're getting this like embedded tax
advantage huge
um because you didn't lose the money but
you get the embedded losses so it's a
super advantageous vehicle for taxes
which is which is wonderful so as far as
the investment process is the same and
and being public versus private accounts
and versus my own money remember we I
own all this stuff personally so losing
money is much more painful to me than
like somebody on Twitter saying I suck
you know and I
I don't give a crap about what people
say on Twitter I do care about my
clients very much so but if you don't
think clients are just as you know they
watch their accounts you know it's like
they're not dumb if you're not doing
well they call you up and they say why
aren't we doing them you know and we try
to do the best we can now in years like
2022 remember we had 20 21 and 2020 and
2019 so we had clients who had massive
gains from test Mass I mean we had a
huge run 2019 2020 and 21 were just
massive for our firm and our our assets
under management more than doubled
during those three years
over a billion dollars you know so those
clients are not unhappy even if we had a
bad year in 22. so they you know our
average account was probably down over
20 to 25 last year
um so it was kind of in line with the
market though I mostly because bonds do
not help us which also sucked you know
bonds went down just as much as stocks
pretty much
um
but now this year we bounced back we're
up 17 18 for clients especially clients
who we got last year are up nicely and
the clients that you know started at the
top of the market in 21 are still down
or even you know so you know it's not
ideal
but it is what it is now what I tell
people is I've been doing this for 29
years 30 years and in 28 2008 I lost
half my money you know as we were down
huge I mean it was a disaster and you
know within two years we had made back
all our money and and rode that bull
market until the until the next disaster
which you know was 2014. so you know
2001 and 2002 you know it was really
brutal for me as well it was it was
actually three years 2000 2001 and two
we had three bad years in a row and we
were down like 50 and then in 2008 we
were down over 50 at one point and
pretty much the whole system I thought
would be done and we had Bitcoin and
then
um and then 2012 was now my third worst
period of time over 29 years but you
know 26
25 other years have been really good
yeah what do you think about uh Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies and obviously
there's a lot of I love about an ETF I
love it more than ever why
because everybody hates it okay what
people don't understand is bitcoin's not
going away
I I'm I'm a Bitcoin investor right you
know like and that's what's kept me hold
through all this stuff never gotten into
all the coins and all the okay
always been a Bitcoin investor since
2014. okay and I've made a lot of money
on bitcoin over the years I've never
realized any profit but I I still have
all this Bitcoin okay
what is horrible about Bitcoin is the
constant pain the industry goes through
because of criminality of the players it
has nothing to do with crypto okay so in
my mind Sam Beekman freed is the worst
thing that's ever happened to bitcoin
okay he's the worst thing
because he goes after takes all these
ads out spends all this money and from
day one I knew this guy was crooked it
was just Shady the whole thing taking
pictures with Giselle you know and I'm
like this guy so now he's in jail thank
God right but he's put this like Paul on
the industry he put all the Regulators
on the industry The Regulators have no
idea what to do so they're just like
boom boom boom because they got to do
something right and they don't like I'm
like SEC just call me like I'm happy to
help you with crypto regulation it's not
complicated because we do it here okay
just treat it like a damn security and
be done with it you know it's like just
be done with it everybody can follow
rules if the crypto exchanges don't
think they can follow the same rules I'm
following because it's too costly
they're full of okay they can
follow all the same rules that I follow
I just went through an SEC audit for six
months last year that was the other fun
part of last year by the way
was in the middle of a bear Market
getting a letter from the SEC going
we're going through your tweets and we
would like to talk to you about eight of
them you know I'm like eight out of ten
thousand that's not too bad you know
so I had to do that for six months but
you know it was it was fruitful it was
good but I think the SEC tries really
hard to protect investors that's their
job nobody's getting rich at the SEC
that's for sure what did you say in the
tweets
um the ones they were concerned about
were really three in in nature but
really was that we would talk about
stocks like Tesla okay and so I would
get on in the morning Tesla be up I'd be
like Tesla stocks up love it in here
great opportunity for investors but then
what was happening at my firm was I have
26 or 27 advisors and all these
thousands of clients and they don't
watch Twitter or anything what I say and
then they're going in and rebalancing
portfolios and managing money we we
still like Tesla but if you had 10 of
your portfolio in Tesla and it rises to
12 or 13 because it was rallying we'll
trim some back because we managed to an
allocation okay so when the SEC looked
at all the trades at our firm they were
like well you had like 800 buys and 600
cells and Ross was saying this on
television but then the firm doesn't do
anything like that and we're like that's
exactly correct because nobody at the
firm cares what Russ says on television
we manage money for our clients and each
day okay we look at client accounts and
re rebalance them based off each
portfolio so there's no correlation
well they didn't like that
they're like well you say you love the
stock but then five guys sold it and 10
guys bought it and this and that and I
said listen there's no correlation
so they go well we agree with that but
you can't do that anymore so if I like
when you run this podcast we talked
about Tesla then we can't trade Tesla
opposite of what we talked about and
individuals at our firm in our own
personal accounts can't trade at all you
know so we basically created blackout
period so that you know it's sort of
arbitrary but I don't think I'm moving
markets like I don't think things I say
move stocks I just don't I I know for a
fact that they don't okay so like you
know if I go on TV a hundred times and
say by Tesla I don't think Tesla stock
goes up I just don't but it just doesn't
matter so so we change our policies and
that's fine with me and we just have to
like jump through a few more hoops and
we have to warn people like I'm going to
be on TV or or this podcast so if you
want to trade Tesla or Nvidia or
something you should do it now
you know
what do you think about Nvidia it seems
like that's the one of our top buildings
yeah it seems like that's the darling uh
do you think that it's overvalued now no
not at all I think the opposite I think
the exact opposite just added to it
personally from in the fun
um and people go you added to a 483 and
it's like yeah yeah and I'll tell you
why
um
I've been on the Nvidia train for a long
long time as long as Tesla or longer
actually
um because I'm a gamer and I found
Nvidia back in the day so our cost basis
and videos like you know 10 15 a share
too so it's been a huge winner for us
it's now our number two stock behind
Tesla so we got like 100 million in
Tesla and now we got like 60 80 million
in video
alone
and um
so you know Nvidia well from crypto
right so when crypto was booming
everybody's buying Nvidia chips why
they're just wonderful for running these
computations and then it was like with
gaming it was like about like the
detailed graphics and like Nvidia chips
were really driving like the best
graphical experiences and then with like
servers it was like oh we should be
buying Nvidia chips for servers and then
when Tesla and autonomy started Nvidia
was the company behind the chips for
autonomy and they started with Tesla
many years ago and they are now the
chips driving autonomy for everybody but
Tesla because Tesla created their own
gpus Dojo chips or whatever you want to
call them specific to Tesla so Tesla
went to Nvidia and said we'd like you to
make chips specific to Tesla and they
were like no we're gonna make autonomy
chips for everybody and Tesla's like we
have specific tasks so we'll make our
own and that's why these companies are
so interesting and valuable is because
of this technology now Nvidia kept
moving forward with server technology
and Ai and then it was like if we build
these because the h100 is not a chip
it's actually like a big box of chips
thousands of chips it's like a super
computer but it's only like I think I
could say it's like 50 pounds or
something it's like a box of chips and
this thing is like nothing like it it's
like a brain like no thing has ever seen
before so the basic premise is Google
Apple Microsoft Salesforce Uber
um
every toast everybody's been Gathering
data forever right so right now at
Amazon web services there's like so much
data right and right now at Azure and
Google Cloud there's just like all this
data but it has to be queried so what's
the purpose of the data it's like our
sales force so our Salesforce we have
all this information about clients but
unless I say punch up all the clients
that need life insurance and then it'll
spit it out to me
there's no like brain involved so with
putting in these AI chips what they're
doing and what chat and generative AI
like language models showed is that now
you can basically talk to a computer
that's basically what it is so instead
of me searching for stuff and
determining the validity of its
information and then using it now I just
ask it I literally do this now every day
I go into chat I go in a bar and I wish
it was more accurate but it's pretty
good and I'll say what are the top
companies in AI computer chips and tell
me a brief description of why they're
good and it's just like boom boom boom
boom boom
okay
that will save me a lot of time I would
add a research this call a bunch of
people you know talk you know so
we're just at the beginning so for us we
use Salesforce semi-firm and I start
thinking about what AI can do for
Salesforce and I'm like dude they have
so much data they can literally like
tell like we could say like find us
business in our book and it'll spit out
all the clients and all of the things we
could do because it knows now I trade on
Bloomberg's platform they have a trading
platform now and I use Bloomberg
terminal and when Bloomberg gets real AI
okay because they're they have
Antiquated data it's like the oldest
system in the world Bloomberg is like
super annoying because it's like it
reminds me of the 80s and like but it
works you know so everybody uses it but
they have all the data on the stock
market they have it all and now they've
been seeing my trading each week
now you throw in Ai and it learns so now
on Monday when I come in instead of me
on a piece of paper this is how I do it
really like I'm going to add to this I'm
going to do this and you know it could
just suggest all these things based off
watching my history and like the things
the metrics that I care about and like
it'll suggest trades for me and such
like that it can analyze news and say
you know these stocks are moving and you
like these stocks and they fit your
metrics and you should really consider
this because there's like a thought
process now in the Computing so this is
the beginning
of turning
Untold amount of data into value
just the beginning is there an
opportunity to take the ETF structure
and basically use one of these large
language models and just have the model
make all the investment decisions yeah
you know that's I think they have some
doing this already and so here's the
problem with it this is the problem with
with full self-driving and it's the
problem with all computers and it's
called like anticipation
okay like the other day I was on full
self-driving and I'm driving down the
street and this lady pulls up to a stop
sign and I could just tell she was going
to blow it like you know like you look
at the lady and you look at her car and
in my head I'm like she's gonna blow the
stop sign I'm gonna have to stop even
though like the car didn't see this at
all and sure enough she blows the stop
sign I stopped because I knew it okay
now the full self-driving car would have
seen her start moving and then stop
there's a difference there of maybe
a split second but because I've been
driving forever in La I have an
intuition that a computer can't have it
just can't have it they can't see what
it can't see
but humans have tremendous levels of
intuition actually like danger you know
like you ever walk down the street
you're in New York right and you're like
uh
maybe I'll go down that street you know
like it's just like you didn't see
anything it was nothing but you just
felt like it was too quiet you know it
was like too quiet so that's the part
that's really hard for computers so
stock picking a lot of owning
Investments is philosophical and it's
like Forward Thinking so like we're
talking about AI so like if you put in a
valuation model and then you put in like
earnings estimates and then you put in
like all the stuff on Bloomberg and like
you have that already like
essentially the computer could create
more limitations to your viewpoints than
help and and so like the way I see
Nvidia in my mind is definitely not the
way the computer sees it because it is
putting in numbers that people assign to
it for earnings for example and then it
creates valuation models based off
assumptions that are always wrong you
know one thing that I'm sure of
is that analysts never get earnings
right
okay now think about 25 Highly Educated
people work on Tesla's earnings every
quarter and every quarter Tesla sends me
the mean you know they send me this
thing of here's all the analysts here's
every number they do every number you
know what I mean these guys literally
that's your whole job
all day is to just come up with how many
cars they sold and what margins and this
and that and they're wrong every quarter
not by much but they're wrong and you
say well if I build all these models
based off earnings estimates into the
future and we really don't know then
valuations into the future are really
pointless right so
you might miss a lot of Investments
doing that
you know like crypto right now or
cannabis right now might be just epic
great Investments and they're ones that
I'm really looking hard at again to
re-enter especially crypto because the
havings next year and now with the
grayscale Victory and now with my
friends at uh Fidelity and
um not my friends at BlackRock but the
other firms are now circling to start
their ETFs when I met with the New York
Stock Exchange when I started my ETF I
asked them personally what's going on
with Bitcoin and they told me until
Citadel is trading them until Fidelity
and and virtue all the people who trade
my ETF see the weirdest thing about the
ETF is there's no correlation to being
like volume on the ETF and like people
buying it and when people buy it
actually like market makers buy the ETF
okay or sell the ETF and it never makes
any sense to me when they buy and sell
like you know we've had approximately
the same amount of shares but like just
the other day they sold at the end of
the month like some Market maker and
Merrill Lynch and then they picked up
the same shares two days later and I was
like was what was the point of that like
I don't understand so it's the same idea
with Bitcoin if you start a Bitcoin ETF
you have to have these market makers so
you have pricing the end of the day
pricing and and these guys want to make
money off all this stuff they make so
much money off my ETF you know what I
mean like I don't make any money because
we're not big enough yet we're kind of
like break even but it's like but it's
super efficient you know so like it's
great but like
to make money on an ETF
after your cost let's say a couple
hundred grand in costs and then your
market makers are making two three four
cents a trade versus one cent a trade on
on a stock why do you think there's so
many ETFs you think we need all these
ETFs you know they're like oh I got five
new ETFs coming out well the top five
stocks ETF uh the 10 best tech stocks 17
new AI ETFs uh four new Bitcoin ETFs you
know it's like how many people have
filed for Bitcoin ETF there's one
Bitcoin you see what I'm saying like
there's eight guys trying to do the
Bitcoin ETF there's one Bitcoin so
they're all the same so once all these
Traders
adopt a structure to trade Bitcoin and
have custodial abilities which isn't
that hard and they're doing this right
now and Fidelity is the leader
it's going to happen and it's going to
happen next year and what's going to
happen is that all the institutional
players are now putting their foot down
in this business and and all the weak
players have been destroyed just gone so
if you want to trade Bitcoin in America
what you got coinbase
PayPal
but those aren't real platforms like
PayPal and square are kind of just
accumulation platforms compared to like
coinbase and coinbase is a nice platform
but I've never liked them
but I like bit tracks and they shut it
down
you know I'm like that was a fine
platform you know it's like all the
platforms are gone so traditional
institutions will take it over
they'll start doing ETFs and Bitcoin
will rise again and everybody will get
excited again but to try to argue that
we don't need a digital currency that's
Global that isn't controlled by a
government it's like it's more necessary
than ever
big bull I have one last question for
you and then I'll let you go you can't
choose Tesla you can't choose Nvidia
what's a stock you own today that
doesn't get enough attention that you
think people should be paying attention
to that I love that I love and it's my
number two holding so I've got Tesla
Nvidia and MGM Resorts okay
like people don't get the gambling
business right now
Vegas was destroyed in covet and same
with Macau okay and it wasn't until
January that China even let Chinese
people out of jail to go out and go back
to Macau and go start living their lives
what we've seen in Vegas the last two
years has just been massive growth of
visitors and now the businesses are back
and MGM has positioned themselves as a
leader in Vegas and also Sports okay and
they've aligned themselves with the
Raiders and the golden knights and now
the A's look to be coming
and now we've got the sphere opening up
in Vegas which will be amazing uh it's
opening with YouTube
and uh and then we've got formula one
coming to Vegas I think in November and
you should see the way this thing is set
up it's going to be super amazing event
followed by the Super Bowl for the first
time in history in the gambling Mecca
now imagine room rates for the Super
Bowl in Vegas
imagine the dollars in the clubs
whatever you know like it's huge money
the next six months of Vegas
is amazing and now you've got Macau is
full again okay so even though the
Chinese economy is garbage that's like
the overall economy China is a massive
country so the people who have money are
all going to Vegas which is the cow and
macau's numbers are back and that is not
reflected in the numbers yet because it
just really started so June was a huge
month July was even bigger you know
August was huge they did have a storm
that knocked a few days out but like
these are like they're back to normal so
these this is great news and we have
online gambling
so now with the demise of the bar stool
app you have one less competitor so
ESPN's now and Penn has got to get their
Mojo going and you basically have
DraftKings and FanDuel and bet MGM and
bet MGM is the only one of the three
that's connected to a casino so you get
perks and all this kind of stuff and so
it has a nice advantage to using them
because you get all the perks and so
MGM has never made a dollar on online
gambling and the next six months is when
they're supposed to become cash flow
positive so if you put all those things
together and you got a stock trading at
forty four dollars that's supposed to do
250 to three dollars a share okay
they're going to reinstate a dividend at
some point soon
um and their asset light now because
they sold off all their real estate
and the profits are just starting to
flow through the shareholders now
um I think the stock is worth 30 to 40
percent higher than it's trading at
today I keep adding to it down here
under 50. anytime it's under 50. I'm
adding to it I'm I just people want to
travel and they want to have fun and I
don't think that's going away I think
leisure travel entertainment
um gaming is just a booming business and
and we're just getting started in the
post covered era so that's that's the
stock that I love tremendously and see
tremendous upside
um and as a solid company it's not a
speculative company
I love the conviction where can we send
people to find you on the internet
Google you know just Google my name and
you'll see all kinds of garbage no um
yeah gerberkawasaki.com is my website
you can follow me on Twitter X at Gerber
Kawasaki or on Instagram
you know threads YouTube you can follow
Gerber Kawasaki on YouTube which is
great I love YouTube we do a lot of
stuff there
um and uh you know send us an email info
at Herbert Kawasaki we do Financial
Planning and investment advice so you
know you need advice that's actually one
of the most important things you do is
build a financial plan and at the same
respect maybe you do it yourself you
want to invest you know in our ideas
climate change uh technology Ai and
consumer businesses and you know our ETF
GK is is a great opportunity for add
some Alpha so you buy the s p you buy uh
some of these concentrated ETFs like
mine and I think you got a great
portfolio
I appreciate it as always we'll
definitely do it again in the future
yeah thanks for having me